Supporting evidence for that kind of
thing.
From a,
from psycho linguistics,
there,
there is a level of,
of categorization that we seem to
manifest more or less automatically or
implicitly.
So for example,
when children perceive animals,
they,
they perceive at the level of cat or
dog.
They don't,
they don't perceive that the level of
subspecies like cat or,
or,
uh,
or uh,
let's say Sam Lloyd,
you know,
there's,
there's this,
there's a natural,
I can't remember what they call that
base category,
something like that.
It's usually specified by very short
words that are easily learnable.
And so the linguistic system seems to
map right onto the,
to the object recognition
characteristics of the sensory systems
that are built right into it.
And,
and if they weren't built into it,
we couldn't communicate easily because
our natural categories,
I think that's it,
but it's probably wrong or natural
categories.
They have to be the same for everyone or
it would be very difficult for us to
communicate.
Okay.
So having said all that,
then the question is,
well,
what are the most,
what are the most real categories?
And I think there's,
there's a real division in ways to think
about this because there's a scientific
way of thinking about it.
And,
and in that case,
the most real categories are,
well mathematical equations certainly
seem to be in the top category there,
the equations that describe the physical
universe,
but then then the,
the hypothesis of the existence of such
things as protons and electrons and you
know,
the,
the material elements that make up
everything,
that's every element of being with the
possible exception of empty space.
Um,
but in the,
in the mythological world,
the categories I think are more derived
from Darwinian by the effect of
Darwinian processes on cognitive and
perceptual function.
So which is to say that we have learned
to perceive and then to infer those
things that are most necessary for us in
order to continue our existence,
propagate live well.
All of those things.
And that would be true at the level of
individual survival.
And maybe it's also true at the level of
group survival.
Although you know,
the,
there's a tremendous debate among
evolutionary biologists about whether or
not selection can take place.
At the level of the group
anyways,
there are these basic level categories
that manifest themselves to you and then
there's categories of the imagination
that you have to infer up from the
sensory domain,
and we do that partly in science by
comparing our sensory representations
across people,
but we also do it by thinking
abstractly,
conceptualizing abstractly and no.
One of the things that's interesting
about abstractions,
it's not clear whether they're more or
less real than the things they're
obstructed from,
you know,
this is a perennial among,
let's call them ontologists,
who were interested in the fundamental,
fundamental nature of reality itself.
In some sense,
independent of conceptual structures.
Our numbers more or less real than the
things they represent.
It's a really hard question to answer
because knowing like using numbers as a
representational system gives you
unbelievable power and there are
mathematicians that believed that there
isn't anything more real than
mathematical representations.
Now.
It depends to some degree of course on
how you classify reality.
That's the problem with a question like
is a a equivalent to be.
The answer to that always is.
Well,
it depends on how you define a and it
depends on how you define be,
so generally it's not a very useful
question,
but you can still get the point that
there's something very real about
abstractions,
incredibly real because otherwise why
would you bother with them?
They wouldn't give you any handle on the
world.
So what's the,
what's the most useful or what's the
most,
what's the broadest possible level of
abstraction and is there any use of any
utility in thinking in that manner.
And I tried to make the case last time
that that in the mythological world
there are three categories or four
depending on what you do with the
strange fourth category,
because the fourth category is sort of
the category of uncategorizable entities
and so it's sort of the category of
everything that not only do you not
know,
but you don't know,
you don't know what it's.
It's.
Or you can think about it as the
category of potential.
I actually think that's the best way to
think about it is that it's the dragon
of chaos is the category of potential.
And I do believe that we're,
our materialist view is essentially
wrong.
I think that the proper way of looking
at the at being is that being his
potential and from that potential,
whatever consciousness is,
extracts out the reality that we inhabit
anyways.
That's certainly the mythological
viewpoint.
And,
and,
but it's not just a mythological
viewpoint,
it's,
it's a,
it's a sequence of ideas,
for example,
that deeply underlies the thinking of
John Piaget and Piaget by the way.
It was very interested in reconciling
the gap between religion and science.
That's really what he devoted his life
to doing.
And so,
and there are other streams of
philosophy and I would say heidegger,
that's phenomenologists are,
are thinking along the lines that are
similar to this as well because
heidegger was concerned not with the
nature of material reality,
but with being as such and,
and,
and so you can extract out the viewpoint
that I just described from,
from mythology.
But it isn't the only source of such a,
what would you call it?
A high
hypotheses is probably the right idea.
So,
so the idea,
you can think about this as a
bootstrapping process in some senses,
in order for anything to get going,
it has to bootstrap itself up and become
more and more complex as it does that.
So it's,
it's like this is the answer to the
chicken and egg problem,
right?
Which was first the chicken or the egg.
Well,
neither.
Something from which both the chicken
and egg were derived,
right?
Because the,
the ultimate,
the ultimate answer to that is the
answer to how there are things at all,
who knows?
But at some point there were neither
chickens nor eggs,
but there were the things that were the
precursors to those things and so they
spiraled upwards in some sense.
And those in the initial protocol
entities,
single celled animals for me,
need to go back farther than that.
But we could say,
well,
single cell animals differentiated over
time.
Right?
And there's this looping process that,
that differentiates out into both the
chicken and the egg.
So,
but what the question is,
what do you need in order for that
process to begin?
And that's really the question of what
the fundamental constituent elements of
reality are,
and the mythological hypothesis is that
there's three or four.
One is the fact that there has to be
something that,
that,
that manifests itself as an observer.
It's something like that,
some kind of observer now where that
process of observation starts in the
phylogenetic chain is very,
very difficult to tell you.
No,
we might say,
well,
there's certainly no possibility of a
conscious observer until there's a
differentiated nervous.